foreign
[Music]
for data and AI
my name is firat and I'm here with my
colleagues Vincent and also materse who
will be taking over from me as we talk
through the session so we have a pack
session actually so what we'll do is
we'll first cover
why everyone is really looking to do you
know data and AI Investments how they
can get value out of that and we'll then
go and look into some of the Innovation
that supports the need as well everyone
is talking around uh you know AI these
days right it is not a secret if you go
down the you know exhibition Hall every
single vendor has something related to
AI but how can you get the value out of
this how can you really see your AI
projects going into production and get
the value is really the key for that and
we'll be touching base to some of the
challenges that we have been observing
and we'll be touching base how things
can come together
really to solve these challenges as well
with the rapid acceleration and you know
where we're titled generative AI this
year d10 AI platform teams are really
presented with new challenges and there
are a lot of challenges firstly around
in ability to enable the organization at
scale usually you find there are few
teams who can traditionally do ml
projects also it
the
in an increasingly complex environment
as well which tools do you use there are
a lot of applications and Tool bases
there also at the same time which ones
are going to make the most impact in
your organization is a key you can see
this as a multi-objective optimization
problem in a way right where do we
invest and where do you get the most out
of it and it is really challenging to
keep up with the pace of innovation even
if we look at the foundational models
and stuff you'll you'll be hearing that
there are a lot of them be coming out
all the time they use models with you
know fever parameters or you know more
parameters and such as well right
and the you know
sorry I'm going wrong direction
and I've been warned about this the
clicker you press down it is not
intuitive and this presents
opportunities for us as well right so
if we can bring all users together if we
make all users as part of the data and
AI ecosystem and if we manage these
risks that and challenges that we see
trade governance that goes not from the
data side but also to the AI side as
well we'll be you know dealing with some
of the complexities that we see and if
we provide the users and the teams with
the most Innovative and the latest
applications and the tool stack they'll
be able to succeed and this really
brings us the you know how you can get
the most out of uh from your data and AI
projects it's
team sports it shouldn't be that you
have a data engineering team and you
have a you know
data science team and they don't work
together we really need to bring them
together and they should really work
together but all of this can only happen
if you have the tool sets that supports
that right the tools that you have
should be able to allow collaboration
but it should also enable the governance
of it as well and you should really
invest into the solutions that keep you
really ahead of everyone else there's an
opportunity cost
I spoke recently today one of the
leading Banks and their CDO told me that
they invested into just over 100 ml
projects and only five of them gone into
production
this there's a huge opportunity Costa
right because they they weren't sure
whether they had the right governance in
place for example to be able to see and
apply and answer also The Regulators
requirements as well
and we are also seeing this from the
analyst community and everyone is really
aligned with the same as well so the
first is you really need to set the
foundation for your data and AI
ecosystem and let's talk to that a
little bit
data warehouse have been around for a
long time they have been around for
really four to five decades they have
really helped us to answer what was in
the past they've been really really
successful but they have been really you
know
expensive as well and they they will
really focused on one specific task
then within the you know past decade or
a little bit more than past decade we
started having the data Lakes right so
the data Lakes came to address some of
the challenges that the data warehouses
themselves had and they were really
looking to answer some of the questions
not just what was happening in the past
but also what is happening now as well
still you know most of them are not
looking into what is going to happen
next and that's where the lake houses
comes and that's where an environment
that you have that you can get
multi-modal data and also you can have
different personas all operating in the
same ecosystem
the good news is that our data Cloud
really data and air Cloud really fits
into this
we have the building blocks that allows
you to have that AI lake house within
Google Cloud
it starts with the complete threat of
the Native Solutions these are mostly
managed Solutions and it gives you the
Enterprise capabilities but in this poll
we'll be focusing on just the data and
AI portion of that right so the core for
the data is within our ecosystem is
bigquery and within bigquery around
bigquery we have the you know the data
proc and dataplex which deals with the
Hadoop side and open source as well as
the metadata management as well and on
the other side we have the vertex AI
which gives you all the capability
access to all the capabilities from the
AI side of things which my colleague you
know Vincent is going to take you
through some of the announcements around
that
and
and that is very similar to what you
would have you still need to bring the
data in you need to process that data
you need to understand that data and you
need to put the rail guards around that
within your organization to be able to
really answer some of the challenges
that we mentioned at the beginning
while this thing that it should also be
able to accessible as I mentioned to
most of the data personas that you have
as well and going beyond the data
personas with some of the new
capabilities that was announced
yesterday with duetai is what we are
also saying too and let's talk a little
bit around that but if we take a step
back
in here you
Enzo data AI platform
traditionally many organizations are
divided into a data organization and an
AI organization right so you have the
key data engineering tasks which you
bring the data in you cleanse the data
you transform the data then on the other
hand then you start doing some data
analysis around that you do exploration
wrangling and pre-processing
and that date site goes and fits into
the ml tasks that you might have you
would be developing your models you
would be doing first your future
engineering selecting what are the key
features that would have the most impact
on the problem that you are solving and
the model that you are dealing with you
train your model and you experiment
around that and this is an iterative
process and then once you are happy you
deploy right and then you serve the use
cases that you have again this is an
iterative process you learn continuously
and you go and alter that
if this acts as a separate entities in
terms of the tool set and in terms of
how the team set up it becomes very
challenging and let's talk around how
some of the tools that allows you to
bridge that Gap together as well okay
so one of the things that you can use
the AIML is if you are a developer for
example you can go and call an API
you don't need to you know train any
model and you can get access to things
for example it can be a vision API you
can go and call a vision API from vertex
right it will be able to give you what
are the entities within that
unstructured data on the other end of
the spectrum you can go and build your
model you can go and train the model and
use specific capabilities that we
provide to the vertex side
most of the users will come into the
middle though more around the automl and
what we call a bigquery which I'm going
to talk in a minute around it as well
whereby you automate some of the tasks
you are automating the training part for
example and you are in you know doing
models of the inference and this comes
back with all the capabilities around
the llms as well these days it gives you
it eliminates the need to build and
manage data pipelines you know let's say
we are using bigquery here and then
generative AI models it also streamlines
the governance and helps you to reduce
the risk of data loss by avoiding the
data moments it reduces the need for you
know writing and you know managing
custom codes as well don't get me wrong
I'm not saying that you shouldn't be
doing that I'm saying that most of the
you know teams your analysts and such
rather you know
more numbers within the organization
right will be able to be part of that
uml engineer is still developing that
and making that available through this
environment and you're testing goes and
scales much further than you could do
just with the data scientists and uh you
know the ml Engineers okay and it really
enables you to break the barriers it
allows you to do this in a secure way
and there's so many you know use cases
around us right so you can as I said you
can call directly unstructured daytime
process you know unstructured data
through that whether it is coming as
text or image or as a vision and that
there's so many you know applications
what it does is though
it gives you the capability to do the
prompt engineering
from the SQL language right you are
accessing record ml
through a data warehouse traditionally
or a data Lake traditionally and it
gives you the ability to prompt
engineering and gives that creativity
to the analysts who are not
traditionally you know focused on doing
the ml tasks right
and one of the customers in fact we we
published a Blog this morning as well
around this uh one of the things that
they are doing is they take the data the
customer interactions that comes through
the ingest us into the lake through
bigquery and they use llms directly from
SQL they look into the sentiment and
they you know generate an email back to
the customer right this is a real
Enterprise use case
that's how you bring data and AI
together
okay
and there's there's more capabilities as
well that you know will be available to
the users for example by using the AI
you'll be you are also Bridging the Gap
between the personas which I'll touch
base in a minute in in a bit more detail
if you are a data engineer
and if you want to uh look into a model
for classifying some of the data that
you are receiving you might not know you
might not you know have experience on
doing that before by using something
like directly from the interface it
allows you to generate that code and
you'll be able to do that yourself it
does a chord completion it helps you to
you know find out errors but it is
focused on the Enterprise use cases what
that really gives us is it gives us the
ability to many users coming together
and becoming part of the data and AI
ecosystem
when we look at it who can actually use
AI today right very few can research
ml algorithms and new ml applications
right
probably you know tens of thousands
a step up is the engineers
still not in you know huge numbers but
probably we have a few million ml
Engineers out there who will be able to
build the models
right the next is we have tens of
millions of developers who can come and
call apis you can bring them and make
them as part of your data and AI
ecosystem
and also we have analysts right analysts
understands the business better than
most of the engineers like myself right
they have the context of the business
if you give them the ability to have
access to very sophisticated you know ml
models they'll be able to give the most
value to you as well
the idea is bringing all of the personas
and making them part of the data and AI
ecosystem
and we can you know really expand that
and we can look into you know how this
democratization of the you know personas
goes beyond as well
it comes from the tools
if the users are using similar tools
right
if they're accessing the same data sets
which is also governed based on the
roles and everything that they have
they'll be able to achieve what I have
mentioned before
and we also announced the bigquery
studio
which is based on a collab Enterprise
which Vincent is going to get a little
bit more detail
but but it is a single unified workspace
that allow SQL and notebook interface
for all data users in one place
you can use SQL python
spark JavaScript or even natural
language you can go and describe because
it has Duets AI built in as well
it gives you the ability to use you know
open source Frameworks like you know
pandas and stuff to you know prepare and
train the models that you have
this really leads into more improved
collaboration
but at the same time with the data
engineering capabilities that comes with
the data quality and you know data
lineage and such through the bigquery
side and dataplex side as well you can
have this scouring a supply all of that
the key is though to focus on maximizing
the productivity
and it goes beyond
that you know everyone is talking around
vector embeddings and such how you can
make access to all the the vector
indexes through traditional uh you know
data sources that you are using well the
good things is that you can see the
vectors as the long-term memory for llms
and now with the capabilities that we
are bringing up you'll be able to use
directly to a SQL Vector capabilities
just like geospatial and such as well
but you know beforehand nowhere to uh
you know Vincent let's take a you know a
different view on what I have been
talking around the top bit is usually
what data analysts and data Engineers
are focused on
right but what we are saying these days
more and more is that being asked to
also do what the bottom bit the
traditional data scientists and ml
Engineers have been doing
you know the green boxes here represents
the ML and the blue boxes represents the
data analytics
and we are seeing and we'll be seeing
more and more impact and we'll be seeing
more of this happening as well and with
that I would like to hand over to uh
Vincent who will take you through more
on the uh bottom part of this thank you
[Applause]
great thanks Rod
um so as everything fraud was talking
about we can have far more impact by
working together bringing skills and
context across the organization into the
data and AI workflows so what's the
thread that really connects everything
so with collab Enterprise
uh that's where we're making the thread
across the data in the iCloud so collab
the public version from Google research
is already used by over 7 million users
but we have been receiving feedback
where users to really use it in
Enterprise production use cases they
need the right security controls that
are consistent across their
implementations on Google Cloud so
that's why we're bringing collab
Enterprise into the Google Cloud
environment with all the security
controls customers and it expect
it Powers The Notebook experience within
bigquery studio which you just saw it's
also the core experience within vertex
AI so it's the same notebook behind the
scenes and we're actually bringing this
interface to more surfaces on the data
and AI Cloud such as dataproc and
dataflow
those will come in the future
this all really drives collaboration and
productivity for data analysts data
Engineers data scientists machine
learning engineers and it's great for
I.T because it's all the security
controls they would expect
beyond that I also wanted to talk about
Integrations between vertex Ai and
dataplex so this brings org-wide
organization-wide search and discovery
of models and data sets to democratize
access and drive collaboration across an
organization
this also comes at a low cost since you
only pay for usage of the data catalog
API and any business date any business
metadata added via the catalog
I also wanted to touch on some
advancements we have with our pipelines
service and accompanying resources
so similar to what we did with model
Garden where we've exposed over 100
different models from Google open source
and third-party we're bringing pipeline
vertex AI pipeline templates in the
gallery so your users can go find
resources that Google has already
developed pipelines for based on best
practice best practices we've seen
internally and externally
this also democratizes access to
standardized templates so that you know
your teams are working consistently
we also added the ability for data
scientists and machine learning
Engineers to schedule pipeline runs so
that you're always and continuously
training your most important models
so the next topic we want to talk about
is how to extend your data and AI
Enterprise writing strategy for
generative AI
so after a lot of thought we ended up
with this point of view on how ml Ops
evolves with Gen AI and we've built
capabilities that seamlessly plug into
vertex ai's platform and bring this all
to life
every blue box is something new that you
would have to think about and that we've
also thought about
and that's what we're exploring today
and all the capabilities we're releasing
today so first if we start with
Discovery this is really where your
users discover models so you we have to
kind of ask ourselves and you would ask
ourselves questions around
what models do my users have access to
how can I find those who has access to
what how do I know how they were curated
and who curated them
when it comes to customization through
tuning you need to know how your data is
being used in that process
how your your tune kind of adapters
might be used when it comes to
distillation
your your organization can get more out
of a foundation model by using less of
it which will increase the performance
reduce cost and reduce latency
and when it comes to prompts you need to
know how those are being used by all the
services you're using and for retrieval
and taking action
how do you know that your or how do you
implement
Jenny I to interact with other Jenny
eyes including taking action such as
booking a plane ticket based on a chat
conversation
and when it comes to evaluating and
monitoring these new powerful models you
have to take additional steps to make
sure everything is going correctly
and for curated in data high quality
examples for specific tasks and for your
domain are even more important to get
more power out of these capabilities
so I'll talk about a lot of the new
announcements that we have in the
context of these four pillars around our
approach for Enterprise readiness
it's all around data governance and
privacy security and compliance support
reliability and sustainability safety
and responsibility
I'll walk through each of these pillars
and bring in the highlights there
so first on data governance and privacy
so we're helping you extend your
governance and privacy to the
customization of generative AI
so
we've heard this consistently throughout
Google Cloud next but customer data is
processed and stored securely along the
way and it's not used to improve our
models unless you explicitly ask us to
this includes your your input prompts
responses and adapter layers
I wanted to highlight tuning so we give
all of our customers the the same
Foundation models but we also know that
you have a lot of proprietary data that
you can use to differentiate yourselves
so we've released the capability for
tuning where you can use a little bit of
your data to tune our foundation models
which creates an adapter layer that sits
on top that you have complete control
over that adapter layer is not used or
given to any other customers it's just
something for you and you can delete it
at any time it just adds an additional
layer of customization on our standard
foundation models
the next things that we wanted to cover
were prompts so just continuing to
reassure you about how Google thinks
about prompts we these we secure these
at every step and they're only used to
generate output for generative Ai and we
do we don't use them to train our models
and on extensions this is the capability
that you can use to connect to other
real-time data sources and to to drive
action such as booking that plane ticket
based on a chat conversation
on security and compliance support we're
helping you manage new artifacts and
parameters
I wanted to highlight our new version of
feature store which was built from the
ground up on top of bigquery and that
makes it so that you can inherit all the
access and governance controls you
already have for bigquery which is great
for it it alleviates data movement which
also lowers costs
and we now have leading low-level
latency for features so that's two
milliseconds
that's great for real-time use cases
especially in services like retail
beyond that for tuning management so
tuning is extremely important now so by
using a Vertex AI pipeline service you
can orchestrate the tuning jobs manage
those jobs and all the outputs get
stored into model registry which is how
your organization can discover and
collaborate
additionally we also implemented a lot
of new security controls and we know you
need this to use these things in
production so VPC security controls CMAC
which is customer managed encryption
Keys access transparency and data
residency
on reliability and sustainability we're
helping you evaluate performance and
manage infrastructure I wanted to
highlight the new evaluation service
which has two new capabilities the first
capability is automatic metrics which is
how you can evaluate the performance of
a foundation model against your ground
truth data and the second is automatic
side by side which is how you can
compare the or compare evaluations of
two different models against each other
beyond that we have Ray rayon vertex
which is a managed version of Ray and it
extends the open source version of Rey
but it implements or integrates very
nicely into vertex AI so training
prediction mlops and security controls
for accelerators and Assurance we have
several new tpus and gpus that are
supported across vertex Ai and then the
ability to create long-running jobs and
training which will help you assure that
capacity and have lower startup times
on safety and responsibility we're
helping you Monitor and moderate the
generated output
I wanted to highlight safety scores
which provide scores based on different
categories that may be that might be
harmful and as as customers you can use
these to maybe tag content before it
goes to your users or block it
completely
beyond that so we have recitation checks
which provide sources from responses
from our foundation models are very
similar to those in the training set so
you can use those and display those
however you'd like
and then for grounding to help mitigate
mitigate against loose Nations we
enabled you to ground our llm and
Foundation model responses in factual
data that you already have yourselves
so with that we also wanted to touch on
why it's so important to make
investments to keep you ahead of the
pack
without needing large teams of machine
learning researchers just focused on R D
finding a good partner is critical
so I want to just briefly high that this
one more time everything in blue is
something that you or we would need to
think about and we have large very large
teams of data scientists ml researchers
who are always constantly thinking about
how to do this for ourselves within
Google for all the different products
such as Google search and YouTube and we
take all of our learnings and we make
that productized through vertex AI so
you'll always be at the Leading Edge
with us
and this is just uh beyond the amount of
people we have I just wanted to kind of
highlight and touch on some of our
history here that kind of proves this
track record I know you can't read the
details and that's not as important but
it really just shows the timeline and
this all started with Hadoop where in
2003 and 2004 we published papers on
Google file system and that was
inspiration for Hadoop
then in 2017 it was Transformers where
we published the seminal paper attention
is all you need and that really
generated a lot of the interest for
generative AI that you see today and we
continue to double down on innovating an
AI
so just to recap here's a lot of the new
capabilities that we talked about today
we encourage you to check out some of
the highlighted sessions later today
give people a second to take pictures
and
so this before I hand it off to Mateos
who's our customer who's going to share
more about their their platform we want
to leave you with this new AI Readiness
assessment which includes generative AI
you can scan this QR code complete the
survey and you'll get a sense of where
you're at in your maturity level and
you'll receive prescriptive
recommendations on things that you can
do across people process and tools on
how to go to the next level
so with that I'd like to welcome matteos
from Grupo boticario who's going to
share more about how they use data and
AI to meet their customers where they
are thanks
[Applause]
good hi everyone
so hello
I'm Matthew Garibaldi from group
let me go to the next slide so I come
here to show a business case using most
of the tools that these guys just
present to you to say that that's true
it works right
and I'm a data and AI director in group
audio let me first introduce the group
uh who is
a Cosmetic Company basically we sell
performance makeups skincare products we
are the biggest Cosmetic Company in
Brazil we are mood brand as you can see
here in the bottom of the slide in most
of our
brains that we sell we are Omni channel
it's a very complex ecosystem there we
work with B2B and b2c and we are in the
trend process we developed most of the
product that we sell since the RND until
they start right and talking about group
of which carry numbers
we have a tree industry in Brazil eight
logistic warehouses seven offices plus
more than 45 000 employees directed
indirectly last year we say we sold 4.9
billions dollars and we are working with
around the far point eighty thousand
stars and regarding this far part 8 000
Stories the business case that I would
like to present to you today because
it's a very complex as I mentioned and
we have a very nice and big challenged
data problem here
uh so starting from the questions uh
once we have all this this information
all this number of store what looked to
be the perfect are Optimizer to retail
footprint using an eye we have questions
like uh what should be the customer
behaviors front of our stores what
should be
um what happened with our competitors
should we open a big a store in a big
city or a small City we have a lot of
questions and despite of that we also
have a to answer is how we optimize Our
Stars that we are open today right and
regarding that we divided the solution
of this problem in six steps that we
present to you guys now and and all of
it then we are using Google Cloud the
Futures here and the first one in the
future we analyzed more than 2.7 000
Futures regarding this problem including
some business knowledge to understand
what we should do
Futures using big aquaries and they also
are very large future star
solution in the second step we go
through the prediction model we create a
forecast model to predict uh what's the
potential sales of each region in Brazil
that we should have and with the
disputation we create a hit matter in
Brazil where we should invest or not our
efforts right right but it's not only
about that we could we should understand
about in the third step our competitors
hello effects cannibalization from other
companies and
elasticity of the demand and with all
these
step two and three together we go to the
step four in which we create a model to
the optimization model to find what is
the best place in solution to reallocate
or create new stores here in the step
two that's the predictive model we use
the light GBM in vertex zingai deployed
in vertices Ai and then the first
Optimizer we use a gravity model also
deployed in vertex AI
in the five step we started the the
final person to understand okay what we
did it works or not uh so we decided to
open three stars in which we pilot if
it's working or not the results of our
predictor model
and in this validation side we also
double checks on Golden rules and at the
end we could compare in this in the last
step the result of these new stars
opened by our model versus the uh the
other stars that were had had in place
we got like eight six percent of a
currency and this is what was very good
and give a green light to go ahead
um
what what are the benefits that we reach
so first I will summarizing three big
benefits the first one
is regarding scalability we could
calculate it for the whole Brazil as I
mentioned it's more than four thousand
uh Stars a currency because we could
look inside these mountains and
efficiency we are efficiency to
recalculating and everything again
quickly and taking fast decisions right
uh and about the the results so
as the green light of the pilot we go
through
2023 open more than 100 Stars uh based
in our model uh this is the best result
of opening star in the last 10 years of
the company and we are very safe about
what we are going we also find more than
um potential locations to open are
reallocate to start from no place to
another and the most important our
return of Investments the Roy are
greater than 108
so comparing with the other stars that
we didn't have before this project right
uh talking about the gcp architecture as
I mentioned in the beginning we use most
of the tools that the recent and farad
just mentioned here since the ingestion
and the storage of the data and the the
deliverable of the value with machine
learning and analytics I believe that
one of the most advice that I should I
would like to leave you here is to give
a good results of a databases cases I
should invest in three components like
first a good data engineer team to make
reliable and single Source data the
first part the second in the data
science team and invest in the data
science thing not at the end of the
project not even in the middle it should
be the beginning
as fire Dimension and the third one is
the system you needed a system in the 20
process to put all these people together
to work and make the the deliverer
faster and quickly for the company to
take good business decisions right
so this is the example so far efficient
I finished I believe that you're gonna
finish the
the presentation